it's time for seen and unseen will we
reveal the stories behind the headlines
and for that we turn to Fox News
contributor Raymond aroyo all right
Raymond Biden
seems particularly intent on securing
billions for
Ukraine well Lori if you listen closely
to the president he thinks Ukraine has
Authority it just doesn't
have Congress needs to pass a
supplemental funding Ukraine before they
break holiday recess before before they
give Putin the greatest Christmas gift
they could possibly give him we also
need Ukraine to make changes to fix the
broken immigration system here we also
need Congress to make the changes to fix
the broken immigration system here at
home he he's partially right Laura
without being attached to Ukraine
funding Congress would be perfectly
willing to ignore our border crisis
entirely but don't you love he can't
even read the notes anymore I mean this
is getting so bad no and it at one point
it was almost like he forgot where he
was sitting at one point in the Oval
Office but is there a way we could
strike up a fund Raymond I was thinking
about this today just strike up a fund
for zalinski to buy him a proper suit
and tie I mean if you are going to come
and lecture us about what we should be
doing with our money you don't like the
sweatshirt you don't like the sweatshirt
Laura it's getting the ACT is getting a
little old he should actually wear a
suit and tie we get it we get it it's a
it's a horrible event a horrible War but
put a suit and tie on we'll strike up a
fund for that but the reality Raymond is
Biden um I think you're right doesn't
know what he's saying anymore so I don't
know how zalinski even kept a straight
face during
this look we're going to alternate
asking questions we're going to ask a
total of each ask two questions and I
will ask the first question uh I will
ask I will recognize the first question
ask
her I'll ask a question
y the real problem is Laura the
president's policy goals are now in
Revolt uh he's pivoting from Ukraine and
he's trying to celebrate his trillion
doll infrastructure spending in between
[Laughter]
his it's great to be here with so many
members who our national infrastructure
advisory Council excuse my bring Pride
back communities that have left behind
when hurricane hits together you
delivered
uh to boosting our resilience and expand
our use of electricity as we expand our
use of
electricity it's making no sense Laura
but at the same time Biden is pushing
infrastructure spending zalinski was out
saying don't spend your money on roads
and bridges America do this not build
roads for today don't do it spend all
your money to the weapon to the drones
to the society to the pensions and
Etc like to their pensions we're now we
we're spending money on their pensions I
mean people are wondering if they're
going to have their own pensions here in
the United States when push comes to
show no it it is absolutely remarkable
Laura I mean you have here a guy begging
he's coming with hat in hand and he's
telling Mayors don't spend on roads and
bridges give me your money this is crazy
we we've given you hundreds of billions
of dollars I mean you've got to draw the
line somewhere I want to go to this
story Laura though it's breaking in the
Iowa State house and it is a display of
Satan erected by the Satanic Temple
we'll put it up in a second the the fact
that this is here is of course causing
outrage everywhere um and and protests
but when you see this thing it's so
outrageous there's an altar in front of
this statue of Satan there it is and
this is put here legally apparently the
IRS
decided that the satanic temple is a
religious organization so there they are
with their little temple in the Iowa
State House inflaming everybody and by
the way it's only there for two weeks
during Christmas that's not by a mistake
that's by Design well maybe they should
get used to the hot temperature with the
candles all right I want to move quickly
to Boston the mayor Michelle woo there
is under Fire for her Christmas party
her assistant sent out invites to the
entire city council which wouldn't have
been a problem of course but it was
supposed to be a secret party of elected
people of color so half the city council
the white half wasn't supposed to be
invited that just came up today and and
half of them are Democrats they're even
upset and believe this is divisive Laur
I guess it's anything but a white
Christmas maybe Blue Christmas can be
played at that party all right well it's
just that's all right Raymond thank you
and also catch Ray hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interview and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else